[Musique]
c'est un petit village isolé de la
basse-côte Nord coupé du monde un
village accessible uniquement par bateau
et par hélicoptère
et comme toutes les communautés de la
région têtent à la baleine se vide peu à
peu de ses habitants
[Musique]
il n'en reste toujours plus qu'une
centaine tous inquiets pour l'avenir
la population est vieillissante comme
ici un village qui n'a pas de jeunes
c'est quoi c'est un village qui s'éteint
tranquillement
symbole du déclin l'école n'était plus
qu'une coquille vide conçue pour une
centaine d'élèves elle n'en accueillait
plus que trois un triste tableau auquel
Yvonne fuent Lambert ne pouvait se
résigner
c'est très important que la place
continue
c'est triste c'est l'école ferme la
Villa sphère
de l'école il y avait pas vraiment de
perspective réelle de d'augmenter le
nombre d'élèves à court terme
arrivé ici il y a trois ans Yvonne et
Mickaël sont tombés amoureux du village
et ont entrepris de tout faire pour le
sauver quand la guerre
ukrainienne a commencé là au printemps
dernier la conjointe a eu l'idée Yvonne
de dire mais pourquoi on pourrait pas
avoir certaines de ces familles là à
tête à la baleine je pensais que c'est
bien pour de ces migrants qui viennent à
une place securitaire tranquille petit
que c'est plus facile pour l'intégration
et l'adaptation
après des mois de démarche Antonina
litsounova ses trois enfants et sa
cousine olyakoulic sont finalement
arrivés à l'automne venu trouver
réconfort et sécurité dans ce village du
bout du monde
les trois nouveaux élèves sont arrivés
juste à temps pour la rentrée scolaire
soulevant du même coup l'espoir de toute
la communauté
ça change la dynamique
ça fait déjà plus d'élèves dans l'école
donc pour nous c'est gros parce que ça
assure dans le fond de la continuité de
l'école ça nous prenait minimum 5 élèves
dans l'école c'est important pour la
survie je dirais du village parce que la
survie de l'école était en jeu
elle serait déjà formé pour mon école
Staline puis ça quand ça ferme d'un
village c'est dur
le nombre d'élèves à l'école Gabriel
Dion a donc doublé du jour au lendemain
[Musique]
arrive j'étais la seule enseignante sur
place tout le monde on compte en même
temps depuis ce temps-là on a engagé des
nouveaux des nouveaux personnels
c'est super stimulant à l'école tetiana
snijana et Vitali les trois enfants
d'antonina se consacrent actuellement à
l'apprentissage du français les progrès
sont encourageants
oui il y a trois
ça va bien merci et toi les cours de
français
occupent aussi beaucoup Olia et Antonina
un patiente de pouvoir plus facilement
échanger avec leur nouveau voisin ici
accueillant si généreux
en quelques semaines une campagne de
financement a permis d'amasser près de
20 000 dollars et des mois plus tard les
dents en vivre et en vêtements
continuent d'affluer de toute la région
je suis plein de boire de vêtements qui
sont rentrés sont rentrés tout le monde
a levé la main en disant mais moi je
peux aider maintenant
surprenant
les enfants ont rapidement pris goût à
la liberté aux grands espaces et au
plaisir de les explorer
[Musique]
vers le centre communautaire pour
honorer une invitation à dîner
au menu des plats mexicains et
ukrainiens une façon de Yvonne et
Antonina de dire merci l'occasion aussi
de tisser des liens on ressent que tout
le monde a envie de se connaître plus
d'apprendre à se connaître puis de se
côtoyer plus les habitants de tête à la
baleine attendent maintenant avec
impatience l'arrivée d'une deuxième
famille ukrainienne La grande séduction
en cours ici et donc loin d'être terminé
en fait elle ne fait que commencer pour
nous le projet c'était pas d'amener des
Ukrainiens étaient à balance c'est ou
des amener mais qui s'intègre que le
goût restait ici c'est 50% qui est
accompli mais après c'est sur des années
que ça va continuer
un projet à long terme à l'avenir
incertain les obstacles sont nombreux le
mal du pays en fait partie
Olia par exemple vit très mal la
distance qui la sépare de son fils
restait derrière
Vladimir 18 ans je ne recrut à
l'Académie militaire
Antonina elle contemple sérieusement la
possibilité de s'installer ici d'y
prendre racine
le calme la nature
œuvre de paix où se sont rencontrés de
destin une famille en exil fuyant la
guerre et une population engagée dans un
combat contre l'exode
[Musique]